let's take a step into the world of
studies
timothy leary who was he and uh
what were the most important ideas
you've learned from him
well i did have the um
opportunity to get to know him
personally and to spend some time with
him
uh timothy leary um
[Music]
well let's start with nixon saying he's
the most dangerous man in america that's
a good place to start
yeah yeah and why did nixon say that
it's because of this uh tune in
you know tur turn on tune in drop out
um timothy leary was just an incredible
advocate for um think for yourself
question authority those were things he
said all the time think for yourself
question authority he was a rebel
he was kicked out of west point he was a
psychologist
who was at harvard for three years from
60 to 63.
before he got to harvard he had an
experience
with mushrooms
in mexico and that he said he learned
more in that
experience than he had in his entire
academic career before then about how
the human mind works
and so he came to harvard wanting to do
research into psychedelics um
and he did some very important studies
both of which well one was called the
good friday experiment
which was whether psychedelics in
religiously inclined people taking
psilocybin in a religious setting
whether it could produce a mystical
experience
that took place at marsh chapel at the
boston university
because it's a little bit subjective or
you could say entirely subjective what
people describe
happens to them he wanted to do another
study
which would be a more objective measure
and that was called the concord prison
experiment and that was the thought if
you can give people
psilocybin mystical sense of connection
type experiences while they're in prison
when they get out
they'll be more pro-social and they'll
have reduced recidivism
so tim did that he also did the
naturalistic studies of giving loads of
people psilocybin and
sort of writing down what their
experiences were the range of
experiences
later on um in his time at harvard he
just
they started doing lsd and lsd is more
cerebral longer lasting not as
reassuring in a way
simon sometimes he's to say that if they
never got into lsd they'd still be at
harvard
with the psilocybin so he was a great
american psychologist but then
he got tired of the psychology game
you could say or he would say that he
got
more and more interested in um cultural
change
and various musicians and artists and
all sorts of people started coming to
him for
the psychedelic experience that they are
in a way for creativity for other things
so he started hanging out with
all sorts of famous people or you know
creative people and
he stopped going to classes all a lot
and um rom das richard alpert
you know had um given lsd to a student
that um romness was
courageous enough to admit that he had
the sexual interest in
they weren't supposed to give it
undergraduates that was about the only
time that they ever did it and
psychedelics just getting more and more
controversial even in the early 60s
eventually got kicked out of harvard and
then he became
kind of a cultural icon for the
counter-culture and
was hounded by the police and nixon and
spent a lot of time in jail i mean he's
an incredible person
one thing that ramdas said is that um
richard albert ramdas said um i'm a
rascal but leary's a scoundrel
what's the distinction um rascal's like
in good fun
a scoundrel is like you can't quite
trust them
i think um uh i do yeah
it's a spectrum of sorts yeah i think
that leary was someone who
a little bit got addicted to media
attention
yeah but i i think that um
overall he gets blamed a lot for the
backlash against the 60s
the shutdown of psychedelic research i
think that he is unfairly
plain for a lot of that i think when you
look back at the 60s
my son the common narrative is that it
was because psychedelic is going wrong
people took psychedelics they weren't
prepared they had emotional breakdowns
they went psychotic they
killed themselves they did this or that
different problems of
people taking psychedelics in um context
that
they didn't feel preferably safe in or
or just they weren't prepared or they
didn't know how much they were taking or
all this that so
the the backlash was because
psychedelics gone wrong
but i think the real reason well that
did happen
i think the real reason is psychedelic's
going right and
people having this sense of connection
and then
the opposite of what the cia was hoping
that it would kind of turn people inward
and take them away from political
struggles it actually
motivated people once you actually um
have these psychedelic experiences your
attitude towards death changes
also this idea of um
death becoming an intrinsic part of life
it's a natural cycle
it's not so much so i think people
realize that you know while there's this
billions of years of evolution
you know infinity whatever that means in
terms of time that we're here for a very
limited time and they end up wanting to
use their time well they have a
lessened fear of death and they want to
build this paradise on earth here now
instead of later
so a lot of people really did get
motivated
to challenge the vietnam war to work on
the environmental movement civil rights
movement women's rights movement
anti-militarism
and it was that challenge to the status
quo that caused the backlash
so leary is someone who in 1990
we had a now maps i started in 86 so in
1990 we had this
conference to raise money out in
california and leary was there and ram
dust was there and ralph metzner was
there and andy weil was there and
terence mckenna was there and dennis
mckenna was there and all these
but there was one point where um
tim was speaking and afterwards i was
asking him some questions and i said do
you have any advice for us
on how to work with the government and
and how to bring these psychedelics
forward that's what we're trying to do
i've got this non-profit for it
you know we're trying to do this
research what is your advice on
how to bring this forward and how to
work with the government
and he said uh [ __ ] the government
he said i am so far past asking for
permission for
anything but i'm glad that you're doing
it
and then he held up my hand like you
know like passing the torch wow
so it was and that's one of my favorite
photographs of me and tim where he's
sort of like but it was after this [ __ ]
the government i'm so far past
asking for permission for anything but
yeah i'm glad that you are
you